feedback feedback
[Music]
[Music]
Monday and i'm looking for portfolio
remarks that other people did about my
project about this portfolio page I
asked for the feedback on ready to
critique I also posted my project and
recalled top forum it's not easy to give
and get the feedback on designs because
it's very subjective however is really
what we're doing we're getting it makes
you better not just onions the designer
but also the developer because you have
to finally implement all of the new
solutions I will look for some
inspiration on Pinterest dribble and if
you could come firm how others that they
in portfolio may eat something maybe
there will be something that will really
inspire me to redesign my portfolio I'm
not sure what should I changed exactly
because the comments are like you know
it's to make the small about the same
thing it's too bright too dark so it's
always very subjective we have to be
careful with that
[Music]
this Tuesday one of the co campers just
surprised me with the answer because the
person wrote that it's it's a pleasure
to work and to learn to learn something
it's better to learn from experience
people like you and if he knew how
beginning level I have maybe human
rights and he continues as we beginners
as we beginners so I'm not I'm rather to
can go so deeply into the code thank you
so it was the response for from my
project review so I did the code review
of the project and try to help a bit we
began I was very often mmm underestimate
ourselves I got the same problem you
know practice makes perfect and also
practice helps you to get rid of this
imposter syndrome and whatever it's
called so everybody's starting some from
somewhere and the thing is to keep on
doing keep on learning and getting
better
developers who have years of practice
but stay in the same language and they
do not develop
there are also beginners in other stuff
they know more they can connect the dots
and learn the new frameworks and
languages faster but still they are
beginners so everybody as a beginner and
the other thing about Colt society is
that we share the knowledge we help each
other and that's great so keep on
learning practice and we will be all
experiencing something as a result we
can share all knowledge of ourselves and
develop as a community keep on doing
[Music]
[Music]
it's Wednesday yesterday I've been
reminding all of the projects for
fronting certificates from free code
camp I've been changing about the colors
in some projects correcting
accessibility or changing about the
layout majority of the changes were the
results of the feedback that I got sure
in the beginning your finger cally there
are that's right I did a lot of work you
know everybody who's a creator loves the
work more than the audience the problem
is that we don't see many things that
other people see because they see the
project for the first time whatever it
is concerning the application is worth
asking the more you ask the better you
know the better your app can look
[Music]
I gained my front end certificate the
first bigger from them certificates in
my career joy of reaching the milestone
is really great it also brings fear and
excitement of the next steps and also
new challenges and another box that I'll
probably needs on my way
Thank You celebrate
[Music]
it's certainly after the celebration day
comes a day where you have to focus once
again on what's next and what's next
because it's just the beginning of the
way I know that I achieved something
that was impossible five months ago the
more you know the more you know that you
don't know I also know how much is in
front of me and I'm more and more aware
of that which is great which is great
because you don't learn if you don't set
yourself for the challenges
[Music]
to sum up a game of the story that I
wanna tell starting from Who I am going
through what I do later how I do it
showing how I do it and finishing on the
option to contact me
Friday
I'm reading the documentation for the
new project it's Friday
in the afternoon and soon I will be
finishing this week of work and I still
haven't reached 500 points I mean the
brownie points from pick up camp but I
don't worry about that because still I
helped other people and I promise to
reach these points before starting react
challenges they I haven't done much on
learning new stuff I was analyzing the
documentation for the project I wanna
get but it was also kind of lesson to
analyze the documentation once again
write the questions to a client so it's
also lessons the week is almost finished
this week I've been mostly iterating
over the project I've done before and
I've been giving and receiving feedback
the problems that I met this week was
not enough time for unexpected things
happening and the next week will be
quite busy because we had Feria de
Malaga in here so the whole city will be
having variant I also have guests from
coal mines with kids so I think that I
have to plan it wisely next week I'm
going plan SAS and flexbox I'm going to
sum up my way to fronting certificates
on meet you I will keep on giving
feedback and browning give up the way
see you next week
[Music]